Judge Jeanine getting an exclusive
interview with Daniel Penny's attorney
the Marine facing a second degree
manslaughter charge in the Chokehold
death of homeless vagrant Jordan Neely
on a New York City subway Daniel's
attorney Steve razor sharing the Marine
side of the story for the first time and
explaining why Penny stepped in
what was his mindset when he put Jordan
Neely in a choke hold
well the mindset is pretty simple he was
fearful for the safety of those
passengers so when he acted his mindset
was to keep his fellow pastors safe
from Attack nearly entering the train
and acting in a very violent manner both
physically and with words he would say
things to the effect that you know I
need certain things I need food I need
this or that and if I don't get it I
don't care if I go to prison for the
rest of my life and the passengers
actually have said that they interpreted
that mean well when would you go to
prison for the rest of your life if you
kill somebody so everybody got the
message there was a period of time where
the situation kind of developed so you
know a period of time to be able to
observe Mr Neely
um you know swinging his arms at
passengers throwing his jacket down
making threats
Penny as an attorney say they have fully
cooperated with radical D.A Alvin Bragg
and were caught off guard by the charges
how did you find out about the charges
well we were told that there was going
to be a grand jury presentation and that
that would take some time and it was
going to be a very kind of a deliberate
process it was not going to be rushed
then suddenly we got a call one night
before Daniel was asked to surrender and
said he's he's got a he's got to
surrender to the police department
tomorrow so at that point where what do
you mean tomorrow this was going to be a
long process Suddenly It's tomorrow
Penny's attorney pushing back on the
attacks that former pres former Marine
response was racially motivated
Daniel has been called a murderer by
some vigilante by others many claim that
he he acted based on race what do you
say to those people none of that is
based on the facts
um
as to as to race it's simply not the
motivation for Danny he is the one that
put himself in danger to save who all
the people on that train that black
people brown people white people it
didn't matter to Danny Danny put his
life at risk to save all those people
has nothing to do with race it's a judge
nice job with the attorney there when he
told you that
Witnesses on that Subway felt that they
were in danger for losing their lives
what what will that mean for the actual
trial everything if this grand jury
makes a decision to return a true bill
which is an indictment and I suspect
that's what's going to happen on the
return date of July 17th uh if they
return an indictment that means
everything because it's whether or not
Dan Daniel Penny was reasonable in light
of the circumstances and the
circumstances are based upon what Steve
Razer the attorney described he said we
were underground we were in a car some
people out self-service some didn't they
were trying to call the police people
were moving away they were afraid and he
said there was nothing that anyone could
do this guy as you heard him just say
was willing to die uh and he was willing
to go to prison for the rest of his life
so all of this is about reasonableness
based upon not one thing but the whole
totality of circumstances and whether or
not Daniel Petty acted reasonably now
the the interesting thing is when I
asked him a question about he's been
arrested 44 times Jordan Neely he said
you know whether he knew that or didn't
know that didn't matter What mattered
was what he felt in that car in that
moment when no one was could escape and
when no police could get in and the fact
that people actually came out afterwards
and thanked him for helping them
indicates that there was a great deal of
fear on the part of people in that car
and by the way you know the interesting
thing today I was talking to someone and
they said I was on that same train that
day and we had a crazy person in our
train car and we were calling the police
and we were like great they stopped to
train the police were coming he said but
they went to a different car he said
they didn't come to my car so think
about the jury if this is a Manhattan
jury new New York City juries know what
it's like to be on a subway I wonder
what changed in Bragg's office because
they were cooperating and all of a
sudden like that something flipped do
you think public pressure played any
role well Andy McCarthy who I had on
earlier did a great piece uh on in the
National Review today where he just
talks about the political nature of
what's going on in New York and that it
you cannot have you know this is not a
justice system where it's based on the
facts of the case and whether or not he
should pursue it and clearly he jumped
the gun because people were jumping down
into the subway and protesting all over
the place and screaming in the faces of
police officers I'm not sure why they
were doing that because the police
didn't have anything to do with the
situation they got there in six minutes
to try to help so
um you know this is going to be very
very very interesting this case and this
young man acted you know spontaneously
based on what he understood about the
situation but I think it will come down
and judge you you can tell me if I'm
wrong on this but to whether or not he
had to restrain him in that way for the
length of time that he did could he have
restrained him in another way that
wouldn't have caused his death
well I think it's going to be based on
the circumstances and we still don't
have the complete autopsy report so we
don't have the toxicology I mean it was
a rush to get the autopsy report a rush
to issue a felony complaint when they
were planning to go to the grand jury
it's a politization of weaponization
Again by a progressive D.A and the
Marine has raised somewhere above two
million dollars Greg for legal defense
yeah I don't know if that's enough uh to
fight a mob I mean right now the left
wants a George Floyd but the world is
seeing Kyle Rittenhouse and the only
reason why we're going to live through
another high tension case is because
City Hall and Bragg caved to a handful
of protesters and I do think it was
coordinated I think that we you
mentioned it Jessica how quiet it got
before this came down and and let's not
forget the protesters were standing on
subway tracks I mean you got to be
seriously crazy to do that unless you
knew that it was turned off or nothing
was going to happen so they knew they
they knew ahead of time
um so it raises this problem what
happens if the trial doesn't go by the
expectations of the protesters this is
what's happening we are being extorted
uh this is the the mob versus the money
he gets money for the defense but the
mob is saying if you don't string them
up the city burns look man they did
billions in Damages post George Floyd
for no reason at all there was there was
a case going on nobody was trying to
hurt anybody dozens of people died
because of those riots the city leaders
let that happen they gave it the okay
they said that it's justified in this
case by Leading these protesters on
their their creating another tinder box
I'm going to be out of this city well
before that happens did you learn
anything from the interview with the
attorney that we just saw there that you
didn't know before
mostly insight into what he's been
talking
about look like and a more clear picture
of what the day looked like and I agree
with Jesse you did a wonderful job judge
um and I just find this case completely
fascinating on every level one of those
where there's almost complete agreement
between people I haven't heard anyone
say that Jordan Neely's death wasn't a
tragedy right or maybe a few jerks have
but nobody
insane or that we would speak to on a
normal basis has said you know this guy
deserved to die and every little drip of
extra information that we get paints
this picture of a marine who acted who
then tried to ensure his safety
afterwards we know that he was breathing
when he let go of the choke hold from
the video and that he put him into the
recovery position and that for me really
changed the way that I view this to know
that this was someone who was clearly
felt like he was protecting people and
he had assistance right and I still
don't know and maybe it's in the full
interview why no one else was charged
with anything because there were three
people that were helping him right in
all of this and they haven't been
charged right not and I find that
strange and I wonder if something will
come of that um but great when you said
people wanted this to be George Floyd I
literally have it written down here that
it just isn't and I think it's telling
to see two million dollars plus in
Daniel Penny's fund and only a little
bit over 100k in the Jordan Neely fund
you know people do give to these and
they feel liberal middle of the road
Republican whatever it is that they're
not getting a full picture the portrayal
of this as just a a white law
enforcement official got on a train and
killed an innocent black man is not
what this is and the people are acting
with their pocketbooks on that front
yeah it's got nothing to do with that
all right if you want to see more of the
judge's interview with Daniel Penny's
attorney you can go to foxnews.com right
now or after the five
hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me
and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcineny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 p.m Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights